the russians are finished at mariopol
now it's behind them they can choose now
to move their forces to the north to get
on with the bigger side of the offensive
and we can see what they're trying to do
they're concentrating their forces their
mending equipment in smaller groups so
that they can attack more intensively in
small areas they're taking smaller bites
mini bites out of the big territory of
the donbass that they're seeking to
control and we can see where that's
happening that's
novosilka for instance the russians have
been dug in for quite a long time now
they're moving out they're moving
westwards and eastwards trying to
actually extend their front at papasna
particularly pophasna that was high
ground that they took a couple of weeks
ago didn't do anything with it but now
they're trying to move out to the north
west and the southwest of papasna in
order to make some breakthroughs and
most important of all that's very done
that is the key to luhansk that's the
northern the smaller region within this
whole donbass
area the russians are on three sides of
severe donetsk they've tried a couple of
times to get around the whole of it get
round to the west they those operations
were a complete fiasco a couple of weeks
ago they will undoubtedly try again and
in the meantime severe donate is in the
middle of an intense bombardment and
it's getting more intense all the time
not least the russians are
counter-attacking in kharkiv last week
in kharkiv the uh uh ukrainians were
able to liberate the city that was a
great victory for them but the russians
are counter-attacking not to take
kharkiv again or to retake it but
actually to stop the ukrainians getting
in behind them being able to cut their
communications and so that's where the
fighting is presently going on
we can see what the russians are trying
to do we can see their tactics we're not
so sure about ukrainian tactics so far
the ukrainians have gone toe to toe with
the russians defending every area that
they possibly can
they may not be able to continue to do
this they may have to give ground and
what they may find is that it makes more
sense to pull back to more defensive
positions and then try to launch a more
strategic counter-attack
i guess by the end of this month we'll
know what the answer to their question
is
however so far though the ukrainians
have done incredibly well in this war
incredibly well the fact is before too
much longer they will have even more
intensive fighting to engage in